we begin this half-hour with new calls
for better pay in the classroom one
Phoenix area elementary school teacher
decided to share her frustration on
social media posting a photo of her pay
stub in Arizona primary school teachers
are among the lowest paid in the country
when adjusted for the cost of living the
salaries average around $42,000 a year
that's about 13,000 less than the
national average
Carter Evans has the story I absolutely
love seeing kids engaged and learning
Elizabeth millage loves teaching but
wanted people everywhere to see what a
second grade teacher salary looks like
so she posted hers on Facebook writing
this is my new pay after taking a few
professional development classes I need
a college degree to make this it was a
raise of $130 for the year millet is
annual salary is now thirty-five
thousand six hundred twenty one dollars
every two weeks after taxes it adds up
to six hundred and thirty nine dollars
and that's not sustainable
earlier this week Arizona teachers wore
red to protest low wages I would eat
them in a boat and I would Laura Mayer
is another Arizona teacher who loves her
job it's nice to be around all that
energy but in order to supplement her
income she works a second job at
cratenbarrel things would be really
tight if I were just living on my salary
across the country inflation adjusted
teacher pay is declining down more than
fifteen hundred dollars between 1996 in
2015 during that same period incomes for
all other college graduates rose by
almost sixty five hundred dollars if you
were a single person trying to make it
on what we make you couldn't you
couldn't do it
in Arizona 42% of teachers left the
profession within a recent three-year
period experts say it's a nationwide
problem turnover is very closely related
to salaries but the most recent data and
the national level show that about 8% of
teachers are leaving each year in a
radio interview Arizona's governor
Doug duesy said he wants to pay them
more but until additional funding comes
through times will continue to be tough
for teachers most my teacher friends who
don't have a husband support or a
spousal supported income have two and
three jobs that they work just to pay
bills and that's not right for CBS this
morning Saturday Carter Evans Los
Angeles I hate to see this there is
nothing more important yeah your kid's
life than a great teacher and we wish
them strength in their in their battle
ahead